I would argue that Britain had reason to
fight the first World War I think we
need to look at those reasons
and I think we need to look at them
treating history with respect Dominic
Sandberg and John Charley have both
talked about how we must have hard
historical facts in fact what they've
given us is a great many
Confections of interpretation
what they've also done is is turn their
faces firmly against counterfactuals but
it seems to me they have produced
enormous counterfactual we see a picture
of a happy Europe United harmonious
Kaiser Wilhelm II sort of Banky Moon of
the continent
smiling benevolently around bringing
peace getting the serbs under control
running the German Empire by the way I
don't think saying that Germany and
Southwest Africa is a good example of
how Germany was really a rather moderate
colonial power is perhaps the one I
would have chosen speak to the Herrero
about that most of whom were destroyed
in the German colonial wars Joseph
Goebbels Joseph Hermann goering's father
actually the governor of Southwest
Africa but that is the side track I'm
not going to go into counterfactuals but
let us remember what the world was like
in 1914 and let us not patronize those
who had to make what were very very
difficult decisions at the time we know
how the story turned out and so it's
very easy for us to say what fools they
were they should have known that
passchendale was on the way they should
have known that Verdun was going to
happen they should have known that Eep
was going to happen they should have
known that the first day of the sum was
coming that it seems to me is like
saying that those who started the
industrial Revolution should have known
that we're going to get climate change
in the 21st century we can't read back
into the past what we know happened yes
we know that the war turned into a
stalemate and it was a dreadful war in
many ways but that was not what people
knew at the time and I think we must be
very very careful to separate that out
and I think what we need to do is look
at what faced those who had to make the
decision in Britain in 1914 we don't
actually know what was said in the
cabinet debates terribly well because
there is no record of those but what we
can see from the Diaries of people at
the time is that they agonized over the
decision it was not an easy decision and
they weighed many of the questions that
we have been weighing here tonight
what was at issue for Britain in 1914
were a number of things and I think it's
very important again to remember that
and to treat those who had to make the
decisions with the respect that they
deserve they did not make these
decisions lightly these were not a bunch
of upper-class toughs saying let's send
a whole lot of boys over to France and
see what happens and these were people
who thought very seriously about what it
meant and thought very seriously about
the Alternatives before them the issues
in 1914 were not about fighting for
democracy and that is absolutely wrong
people didn't go in to the first world
war thinking they were fighting for
democracy nor did they go in if I may
disagree with that great historian
Michael Gove saying we are fighting for
a liberal International order
you did not see people lining up outside
the recruiting statement saying goodbye
mother I'm off to fight for a liberal
International order
what they thought they were fighting for
were a number of things
they thought they were fighting for the
rights of small Nations and that meant
Belgium the German plans called for an
invasion of Belgium Belgium which was a
neutral country its neutrality had been
guaranteed by the European powers
including Germany itself that was what
really swayed David Lloyd George who was
one of the leading anti-war figures in
the cabinet up until the summer of 1914
he wrote to his wife in North Wales and
said we cannot stand by and see the
rights of small Nations violated like
this and I think there was a very strong
sense in Britain at the time that
Belgium was defenseless it was attacked
unprovoked by Germany the Germans sent
an ultimatum to the Belgium government
saying we want you to show that you will
be friends with us so would you please
hand over your Frontier thoughts and let
us go through and attack France and the
belgians chose to resist and paid a
terrible price for that we now know that
it was not all propaganda about German
atrocities in Belgium during the first
world war a number of that large number
of belgians civilians was shot out of
hand large numbers taken against all the
laws of war to do forced labor in
Germany the ancient and beautiful
library at luvan was deliberately burnt
by German soldiers enraged by the fact
that they were encountering resistance
from the small country Britain also had
obligations to France it had built up
those obligations over a number of years
it had held military conversations with
the French in which the British had said
look we will when a war starts send our
troops to this place to this Railway
Depot what Arrangements will you make
the French had every reason to expect
that a British force would come to their
aid similar Naval Arrangements the
French had polled a lot of their ships
into the Mediterranean to protect sea
Lanes in the Mediterranean assuming that
the British would defend the French
coast along the channel and in in the in
the Atlantic
more than that there was a general sense
that the British and French worked
together and so the French did have
reason to think that the British were
with them were on their side and please
let us remember France did not attack
Germany in fact the French government
pulled its troops back
220 kilometers from the Frontiers in
order to avoid any provocation it was
Germany that attacked France without any
provocation whatsoever so there were
moral responsibilities I would argue
there were not legal responsibilities
but certainly responsibilities had built
up over the years I think there was also
the question of British interests was it
really in British interest to let
Germany dominate the continent the
British yes have wanted a balance of
power in Europe or what they have not
wanted is a single hegemon that's why
they went into Napoleonic Wars to
prevent that happening that's why they
formed coalitions against Louis XIV
that's why they saw they had to go into
the first world war and that's why they
saw they had to go into the second world
war more than that the British felt and
I think this was not just those sitting
in Whitehall this was the people who
went to join up including my own
ancestors who felt they were defending
something important they felt they were
defending a way of life they felt they
were defending home in Harris they felt
they were defending values which they
thought were important let's not treat
them with condescension they saw thought
they were fighting for something
important and let us think of what
Germany might have been if it had won
this is not a counterfactual these are
strong probabilities Germany was an
uneasy country it was not the
militaristic nation of caricature but it
was a nation in play there were
different forces within Germany that yes
there was a growing Socialist Party yes
there were German liberals but there was
a very very strong and reactionary upper
class many of whom saw a war as a very
good opportunity to get rid of all the
things they didn't like as soon as the
war broke out the Kaiser and his Circle
were talking about getting rid of the
reichstag suspending the Constitution
and in a very Sinister four taste of
what was going to come rounding up the
Jews and getting them out of Finance
limiting the power of what some
reactionary German saw it was too
powerful German a German Jewish finance
and it was not a country that was
necessarily going to be well disposed
towards Britain if Germany had dominated
the country would it have held out a
friendly hand to Britain I don't think
so Britain so many were already trade
rivals the Germans had started a naval
race with Britain knowing that for
Britain the Navy was its shield and its
defense and the way in which it linked
to its Empire and protected the British
Isles it had already tried to stir up
trouble in the British Empire the idea
that Germany would have said to the
British a triumphant Germany would have
said to the British hang on to her and
probably we don't care about it is wrong
the Germans had been intriguing with
Indian nationalists who had been to
Berlin who had been encouraged by the
Kaiser the Kaiser is not just a comic
Opera figure he's a meddlesome and
dangerous figure who spoke too much and
said too many things but that doesn't
make him any of the less dangerous the
Kaiser had proclaimed herself already in
the 18 19 1890s the protector of all
Muslims around the world and of course
he was going to call a Jihad almost as
soon as the war started to encourage the
Muslim citizens of the British and
French Empires to rise up against them
and so to assume that this would have
been a benevolent Germany who would have
said to the British Wars over we've got
the French under our control we've
annexed Belgium and the Netherlands
we've basically dominating the center of
Europe Austria-Hungary is now under
control keep your Empire we're friends
we don't really wish you any harm I
Think We're Dreaming and I think our
opponents are dreaming if they think
that and let us also remember what
British entry into the war did this is
not again a counter factual the British
expeditionary Force
turn the tide at a time when it looked
like France was going to be defeated we
will never know how close we came to
repeat of the summer of 1940 but without
the British expeditionary Force without
the first battle of the Moon I think it
is highly likely that Germany had won so
were the costs too high we can't know
and it is not for us to tell those
people then that the costs were too high
but they were no higher in terms of
lives lost than they had been in the
Napoleonic Wars in terms of British
population at the time 10 million
British in in the in the in the period
of the Napoleonic Wars over 300 000 dead
in the set in the first world war 46
million people in the British Isles and
almost half a million dead and that of
course isn't including the Empire as
well the Empire paid a very heavy price
but speaking as a Canadian we didn't
think that price was too high and so I
think the motion should be defeated